allora ragazzi è passato un po di tempo
l'ultima volta che ho giocato a getting
over it
ringraziando a cristo anche a parte
questo è l'uscita è uscito è da un po
che sta girando sta roba di just arbus
che sarebbe sto gioco dove tu il ata non
ho ben capito
vediamo bella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti allo episodio di un gioco che
assomiglia getting over in grazia di dio
continuano a farne che fortuna è ragazzi
spero ci siano i check point perché sarà
un casino allora allora allora ok ok
devo anche capire come funziona perché
il mio corpo non funziona molto bene non
mi dà la propulsione giusta ma dall
l'angolazione ragazzi è importante
perché porco del demonio non sono capace
perché non sono capitato in alto a
sinistra vedete c'è una specie di barra
di caricamento della potenza che sto
dando che non è proprio idilliaca
mannaia la morte mannaia ok ora piano
bravo ma ndo non ci credo bravissimo
proprio lui ho fatto esattamente quello
che volevo fare
no no sono di solito sono vivo aspetta
aspetta dove siamo non lo so no beh
allora demonio il fatto che miti qui
proprio muovere con le braccia e quindi
non è che non è che ti lanci e va a
tutti puoi muovere con le braccia e
questo il caso di tipo in happy meals
alla mio dio santissimo ok ma qualcuno
l'ha mai raggiunto il finalista già
costa 4 euro ragazzi ve lo dico in
anticipo mai finito stop orco demonio di
gioco c'è qualcuno l'ha finito si può
fini c'è la domanda è si può finire
perché se io riccato dopo un ora che
gioco ricado all'inizio mi ammazzo cioè
non sto riuscendo a fare la prima parte
ragazze veramente un casino cioè tipo
che ti gov e ritma peggio perché qua non
capisci proprio in che direzione 6
rivolto pure piuttosto casino lo sto
riuscendo a tornare parco demonio porco
del demonio morto porca vacca poi giorni
da inserire sulla roccia di merda atmo
tonda di dio
io veramente il giuro su dio da mimì sta
facendo salire una rogna di quelle che
vi giuro guarda che la cresima cielo ma
ancora per poco
allora porca [ __ ] che testata ce la
fa ad andare dei 61 tritto rimasto
registrano si sta registrando hidri
dritto dritto madonna devi andare di
soldi sopra ok
l'ho fatto così bene all'inizio ok ok ok
perfetto perfetto questo avevo fatto
proprio adesso pia piano visto che ho
piano bravo esatto e adesso spingiti
fortissimo si no sono caduti in un punto
ancora accessibile
ok ok non sono più un punto accessibile
porco demonio niente ragazzi ci ho messo
due ore per nulla porca vacca sedi no
ragazzi io veramente mi giro cioè non ho
mai giocata na roba così
a parte che ti poveri inguardabile cielo
qui lingua è un gioco inguardabile
non si riesce a fare una sega non resto
si scende a fare niente per respirare
casseri e su una carrozza all'inizio una
nomiche incredibile mi giurò ragazzi è
veramente e la rogna fatta gioco come
madonna guardo giorni a tua madre al
rogo come streghe cerri bill e non si
riesce a fare una casa una cazzo di cosa
lì non ci possa arrivare direttamente e
l'abbiamo capito quindi vado
direttamente qua e poi qua ok
stessa cosa per adesso non ci posso
arrivare ok perfetto
sto gioco qua non puoi aspettare di
arrivare da un'altura all'altra devi
fare tutto di prima come se tu giocasse
a calcio di non puoi stoppare la palla
va tutto di prima
perché se stop i casi porco del demonio
una cazzo di roccia un'ora e mezza non
so cosa dire ragazzi lingue sono linee
all'inizio di luglio io lì ripartire da
zero cioè a questo punto un'ora e mezza
sono fermo all'inizio inguardabile non
si può fare niente se tu pensa se arriva
in un punto fattibile cioè ad un punto
più avanti che cado giù che li faccio
tutto da zero non lo rifaccio che non si
può fare una roba ingest infatti vi non
si può fare non ci arrivo
cosa faccio niente cambio gioco ok ok va
bene
rifacciamo quella roba di prima che mi è
sempre venuta e stavolta indovinate un
po non mi è venuto bravo rifallo beffe
ok pian piano mi aveva pugno rifacciamo
no cosa che fai scemo questo è scemo
perfetto no io perché
[Musica]
insomma no io non sono veramente non è
che cosa
porca put addio santissimo per arrivare
qua c 28 ore ai ragazzi in guarda solo
per arrivare qua non è non è niente
ancora ce la sta facendo nulla madre di
dio ok no no no no no ok state forse mi
sono salvato ok sono salvato incredibile
meno male che parlo meno male che parlo
meno male che parla o niente
dopo le testate al muro che guarda
perché non riesci ad andare o è perfetto
pian piano piano bianca ok da qua ma
perché fai questa cosa
madonna perché perché faiotto capriole
che cazzo sei cosa fai danza classica
cosa mi rappresenta
ma perché fai questa cosa ma cosa ti sta
cosa stai facendo
cosa fa arriva di fatto capriole a cazzo
perché ci ha voglia e file e prima
allora fai la dei per leone fai adesso
ste cazzo di capriole falle no alle pale
adesso no adesso non le fa le falìe
guardami sono sparato subito perché
tanto gara torna indietro torna indietro
rifacciamo fa niente ok buono e sparati
per una volta cosa non fare cosa faccio
no infatti i ragazzi non si può fare
no non è fattibile non è infatti vi è
infatti non si può fare c'è quella non
c'è neanche una sorta di c'e poi non si
può fare non ci arriverò mai più e
infattibile no non vi rende no ragazzi
non vi state rendendo vero non so come
spiega non si può fare
non si può giuro su quello che voi non
si può fare questa cosa
io sono arrivato ad un punto dove una
riga mai più civile per arrivarci già
ovvero state vedendo ma dopo è che dovà
ma neanche a guardarlo cioè non so
neanche come si come posso approcciare a
quel punto proprio una roba
inconcepibile nel mondo poi tutto sto
casino per un cavaliere senza gambe c'è
ma che cacchio ma poi marcire per quanto
mi riguarda un po più indietro cazzo
anzi non mi ci butto io se io torno
guardo indietro vado di qualche cosa c'è
di qua c'è qualcosa un mood mi sono
inglobato in un muro fantastico ma non
c'è niente
mi spieghi chi cazzo sei ma cosa abbiamo
iniziato tutto
rifacciamo al video questo non avessi
fatto niente fino adesso mi hai animi
anche righetto la stessa cosa all'inizio
con tasti se tu pensa se dopo un'ora che
giochi cadili e colorati di parad ice
salve sono l'unico ad aver fatto sta
roba io veramente ho finito di vivere
io non ho neanche un video su cui
paragonarmi perché non c'è nessuno che
l'ha fatto solo fatto solo io perché
solo io so trovare sti giochi del caffè
nella mia vita solo io riesco a portare
sti giochi perfetto perfetto sono
l'unico a portare sta a me sono contento
di essere unico proteste non potevo fare
fort night no come ciccio gamer
se oggi non mi faccio banner e da
youtube e guardano storto
che cos'è sta cos'è cos'è cos'è o diamo
fortissimo fortissimo deve usciti la
famiglia dalle braccia
ok
[Musica]